[Captions by Y Translator]
There's no better feeling
than taking ordinary items,
and reorganizing them into
something completely different.
So for this video,
we're taking Lego Technic sets,
and converting them into
powerful high-speed racing drones.
[Music]
Now, you might be wondering
where Nate is today.
He is off prototyping.
So for this video,
it's just going
to be you and me,
and I do have
a confession to share.
When I was young and growing up,
I never got a chance
to play with Lego.
Honestly, the very first time
I ever played with Lego was
to make the Lego Gummy video
that is now the currently the
number one video on our Channel.
But that is all
changed this year.
We've teamed up with Lego.
They reached out to us,
and said, what kind of cool
things could you do with Lego?
So this gave us a fantastic opportunity
to put our minds into gear,
and play with some Lego.
And I have been playing
with a lot of Lego.
Let me show you what I mean.
Lego started sending
us all these kits,
and my very first experience
with Lego was actually
on the floor with
my seven-year-old son,
where we spent
an afternoon putting together
this Lego Ninjago Ice Tank
that I believe belongs to Zane.
And that was really
cool experience.
There were so many
different parts of this
that we're a complicated build
that taught me more
about engineering, mechanics,
and things of that nature.
If you take a look at it,
there's a lot of parts
that move, it disassemble,
and when the tank tracks move,
it actually throws
a transmission to gear that kind
of cycles this giant
whatever it is in the back.
And my favorite part is
that it's got a little cannon
that actually shoots.
This semi tractor-trailer unit
was really fun one to build.
I learned a lot
about mechanical engineering,
especially in the back.
There's a dual
axle differential,
which allows the four tires
to turn independently
with each other.
I thought that was
a pretty clever system,
and you can see there's all
kinds of knobs on this thing.
You can steer the front tires,
the doors open and close,
the seats in the
front will recline,
and the back here,
we've got two lifting cranes
that take this cargo container,
and can actually lift it up,
and set it down on the ground.
There's also a place
for the fifth wheel to attach,
and you can raise
and lower the trailer
using this other little
knob on the side.
Taking a look under the hood,
you can see the engine
actually has pistons
that move up and down
as you drive it.
And perhaps the biggest project
yet is this 4000 piece
industrial Digger that I made.
It's super complex,
a lot of moving parts,
and it looks absolutely insane.
[Music]
So after countless days playing
with Lego Technics,
building all of
these different projects,
I would consider myself
fairly well acquainted with
how these parts work.
So when Lego came to me
and said what can we do
that's really cool,
unique, and out-of-the-box.
One of the first things
that came to my mind
was building a Lego drone.
Now, we don't want to just
build any kind of drone.
No sirree.
We want to build
high-speed racing drones,
which means these things
not only need to be able
to look cool, they need
to be extremely stable,
and withstand vibrational forces
of brushless motors
spinning over 30,000
rotations per minute.
Here's the basic idea.
We're going to start
by building for identical
legs for the drone,
then sandwich them
between two Lego plates.
We're going to add
motors, propellers,
and FPV camera,
and then drop in this thing
we call the brain
that connects everything up
and makes it all work.
Now, these drone
prototypes actually work,
Lego Corporation is going
to fly us over to Rhode Island
to get together with the host
of the Rebrickulous Channel,
Tyler and Dimitri,
and pit them together one
on one in an actual high-speed
drone race in an indoor arena.
And through the magic
of editing,
that video is already happened.
There's a link down
in the description right now.
You can go and see the results
of whether or not those drones
actually worked.
Go check it out.
Now we've got two main
parts of this build,
one is the actual build,
which is 100% Lego Technics,
and the second are all
the drone components
that were going to bring in,
and lay on top of it.
We're gonna be doing
that in collaboration
with a real drone racing pilot.
I'll introduce you
to in a minute.
But first, let me show you
how to get started on the legs.
We're going to be making
four different legs
for this platform.
All of them are
absolutely identical.
I'm not going to list all
the names of the parts here,
because there's too
many of them.
But if you go to our website,
we do have a PDF
that you can download
that will take you step-by-step
through the rest of this build.
In the meantime,
just take a really good look
at the pieces we got here,
and let's click them together.
[Music]
Now, you notice we got
four different arms here
that are absolutely identical.
Now you can have fun with these.
You can change the color
of the main support beams.
of the inside beams.
We went ahead and did orange
and gray and white here,
because to us this
is going to end up looking
kind of like an X-Wing.
On the end here,
which is going to be
the center part,
you can see we put
these blue posts,
and we need those
because that's going to help us
connect them to the frame next.
Now, the frames were using
our 5x7 open frames.
We're going to using
two of them,
and I prep this one already
by taking four little posts,
and using the single side,
pushing down into
the base there.
There's a little ridge so you
can't push it any further.
With four of those poking up,
we're ready to add the arms.
Because these are completely
symmetrical in either side,
it doesn't matter which way
you click them in.
You can literally click them
in upside-down, right-side up.
It doesn't matter
because really,
it's the same on both sides.
With the two parts
of our plate assembled,
you can see this resembles an X.
Now because these posts
in the middle, you can see these
can open freely to the center,
but they won't go
any further outward,
because the post
gets in the way,
and that's exactly what we want.
The next thing to do is
to be able to reinforce these,
so there's not much wobble,
and no play to them at all.
So for that,
we're going to be building
a sandwich to compress
the legs together.
Then use to M15 support beams
to build a friction fit,
and lock the beams in place.
These two pieces are the parts
we want to build next.
We'll show you what they're made
of in just a second,
but I just want to focus
attention on this one.
You can see we actually built
a little camera mount into this,
where our FPV camera
is going to sit.
FPV stands for
first person view,
and those are like the eyes
of the drone pilot as
their racing down the track.
That's going to be sitting
right here on these brackets.
For the top and bottom
sandwich plates,
we're going to actually build
in three different pieces.
We're going to build
the top plate first.
Then we're going to build
the camera mount,
and then we're going
to build the bottom plate,
and these are the different
pieces we're going to be using.
This is how they go together.
[Music]
All right, with a few snaps,
a few clicks, we've got
our top piece finished.
You can see we've got
corner brackets holding
everything together,
and the reason we want
the corner brackets is
because that's going
to be our friction point
for pushing the arms together
and creating tension.
Let's do the camera mount next.
[Music]
So right there,
we have our support beam
and our camera mount complete.
All we have left to do is finish
our lower support brace.
[Music]
There's our lower support frame,
and you can see it's got
two pegs sticking up,
which will marry perfectly into
base of our camera mount here.
When those click together,
we now have assembled unit.
Our camera assembly
and our lower frame
will be one piece.
Now, we're just going to put
this together like a sandwich.
We start with the top piece,
we take the X,
and place it in the center,
making sure
that our corner brackets
are facing down toward it.
Then we take our bottom piece
with the corner brackets
facing upward toward it,
and we're going
to put those in place.
And this is the part
where now we determine
which is front
and which is back.
Because the camera mount
is facing forward.
Now, if you look closely,
you can see this M15 beam
doesn't quite line
up with the holes,
and that's exactly what we want.
We have to stretch
the X apart to get
these the lock into place,
which creates a friction fit,
and reduces the vibration.
That's a good thing.
We want to do the same
thing on the back.
So we're going to take
another M15 beam
with two black pegs,
and pop those
into position as well,
and just like that,
we've got the basic frame
for our stretch
X racing drone complete.
Now, there are a couple things
we need to do before moving on.
First of all, this
is just sandwiched together.
It's literally going
to fall apart.
So we are going to have
to bend the rules a little bit,
and use some fasteners
to clamp everything together.
Now, the holes
in the Technic beams are
actually the perfect size
for accommodating number
10 machine bolts.
So I went down
to the local hardware store,
I picked up 1 and 1/4 inch machine bolts
that pop all the way through,
and the hex nuts are just big
enough that you can screw them
down from the bottom,
and they will line
up almost flush,
which is going to be
really good thing for us.
I got 3/4 inch M4
that pop through these holes
almost seamlessly and support beams,
and that just make sure
nothing is going to come apart.
It's completely optional.
It will work without it.
But if you want to just be extra sure
and actually race these things,
we would recommend it.
All the essentials
are now in place,
so it's time to add
the drone components,
and for that,
I'm bringing in my friend
Spencer AKA Drone Pilot Spuder.
So I'm Spencer,
I've been flying drones
for about two years.
I fly into the handle of Spuder,
and drone racing is one
of the fastest growing sports
with over 30,000 people
flying every year.
I've been to some of
the largest drone racing events,
and flown with some
of the top Pilots in the world.
I got together with Spencer
because up to this point,
I really had no experience
with disassembling drones
and putting them together.
At first, I was looking
at using some other companies
parts and putting together.
But then, Spencer,
you came over with some
of your equipment,
your actual Pro
drone racing drones,
which made it a lot
easier to figure out
how we're going to make it work
with this Lego base.
Let's take a look at some
of your components,
and tell us about what they are
and how they work.
On a drone,
there's a couple
of main components.
They all work together.
They're interchangeable, kind
of like computer parts would be.
You start here with the camera.
This is what the pilot
actually sees.
It sends an analog video signal
up to these goggles
that I can see.
It's kind of like Real
World virtual reality.
Yeah, very much
like playing a video game.
Down inside the drone,
there's a couple other parts
to help me communicate
with the drone
with my transmitter,
and also gives me
this video feed.
There are six main components
that are absolutely essential
to making a racing drone work.
First of all,
we've got the flight controller.
The flight controller is
like a little computer
that knows what
the orientation is of the drone.
The next thing you
need are the ESCs.
The ESC are the part
that actually give
power to the motors,
and tell which motor
to spin faster and slower.
The third thing is the motors.
These motors are lightweight.
Those spin a 30,000 RPM,
and up to a 15 to
1 thrust-to-weight ratio.
The camera here
in the front transmits
these goggles so I can see
what the drone sees.
It's like being
inside the cockpit.
And this camera
transmits in analog,
which is actually
an older technology,
but it's faster to the goggles.
If it was transmitting
digitally,
the latency would be so much
of a gap that the drone
could actually crash
before you see it happen.
Along with the camera, the Drone
has a video transmitter,
which is basically just to send
the signals back to these goggles.
The transmitter antenna
actually receives a signal
from your remote control.
So whichever way you turn it,
that's the way the drone goes,
and you do it with one
of these things.
There's a couple different
protocols of these use.
This is probably
the most popular one.
Now, essentially,
what we've done is we've taken
all those components,
and in the spirit of Lego
we want to make this
as plug and play as possible.
So we developed this thing.
We call it the Squiddy.
We're actually really
impressive about this.
We used a 5x7 open frame,
and we were able
to find circuit boards
that stack together,
and fit nicely right down
through the center.
You see all the wiring flows
down through the bottom,
and we've designed
with banana connectors
so that we can plug
into each individual motor,
and the camera as well.
These red and black wires
on the back will connect
to the LiPo battery
that powers this.
It doesn't get a lot
of time in flight.
Really only will last
for about two to three minutes
when you're really
powering these things out.
The batteries themselves are
about just under 15 volts,
but can pump out up
to a hundred amps,
which is absolutely insane.
Because weight is
so important when racing,
all the smart electronics
that would add safety features
are removed from these.
These are just raw batteries.
You need to be careful
when you charge them.
The thing I love about this
is you just take the top panel
off your drone frame,
pop this into place,
connect everything up,
and it's ready to fly.
But right, now let's
just take this top plate,
replace it with our Squiddy,
and move on to adding
the motors next.
These little cameras are
only about 20 to 30 bucks.
It's really cool because if you
put the screws in beforehand,
they actually just snuggle right
into these brackets perfectly.
You can literally just
pop them into place,
and they stay in place,
but the camera itself
is still adjustable.
[Music]
So we just dropped
the fasteners into place here.
We've got everything
pretty well assembled,
and we've routed the wire
so that it looks pretty clean
from the underside.
We've got three different cables
for each motor running out
to each respective area.
We have two little wires here
that will run to our LEDs,
that we have just going
through the center at the back.
That little tail
sticking out the back
that looks like a turtle tail
is actually the transmitter
for the video transmitter,
the VTX.
And then we also took
the receiver wires.
They're very thin.
They look like bug antenna.
This puts the wires
at a near 90 degree angle,
which means we have
the best chance of being able
to control the drone.
We also took a velcro strap,
and drill through these two
holes so we can take a battery,
and attach it to the bottom.
That way if you don't feel
like building a landing gear for this thing,
you can actually just
wrap the battery,
and your good to go.
Keeps it very lightweight.
The little pieces
that are in the ends
of the arms here are these
little H-shape pin connectors.
They have two holes in them,
which we found are
absolutely perfect
for attaching the motors.
Now, I've still got
them attached in here,
so you could just
touch the motor,
but the reason I
like this design so much
is you can have multiple motors,
and if one of them fails,
you can just click this out,
click the new one into place,
plug the wires back in,
and you're good
to go within seconds.
Most motors use
standard connectors,
which just happens to be
the exact same dimension as
this Lego Technic part.
Just happens to be
absolutely perfect.
Exactly 16 millimeters.
So this just connects right here
on these motor mounts,
and then we put
two screws right through.
On these motors,
I've added these connectors
so you can swap them
out very quickly.
Now, all we have to do
is make three more of these,
swap them out with
their existing connectors,
and we're just about finished.
So we have all the motors
connected and attached.
Now, I just went ahead
and randomly plugged all
these different cables in.
So we don't actually know
if the motors are spinning
the right way or not.
The direction the motor
is spinning is very important
to actually getting
the drone to fly.
These drones run in open source
software called BetaFlight.
We just plug it in,
and then we can change
motor directions.
This is called a smoke stopper.
If there's any short circuits
in our electronics,
this will prevent
them from frying.
[Music]
Now, when you are
attaching the propellers,
here's the only thing
that you need to know.
You want these things
to cut away from you.
So when you line up
the two propeller blades,
it almost look like to knife
blades cutting away from you.
One is going to rotate
counterclockwise.
The other one's going
to rotate clockwise.
So if you look at them,
and you line up the blades,
you just want them
both to be pointing away.
And of course on the back,
they cut the opposite direction.
They cut away to the back,
they cut away to the front.
If you got those on correctly,
it's time to add the nuts.
Oh, by the way,
I also put together some
of these cross beams
that we can put on top
for two reasons.
One, it will help protect some
of the circuitry if we do crash,
and number two,
because we actually use them
when we went and filmed with Lego.
And if you've already forgot,
we have a link down
in the description where you
can go see that video right now,
and check it out for yourself.
There were some unanticipated
events that happened.
There may or may not have been
a mid-air collision.
You're gonna have
to go see for yourself.
It was a great event.
Put a really fun twist
on this whole project,
so links in the description,
go check it out.
There you go guys.
Our drone is finished,
and ready for what we
call a hover test.
This means we get
to hook up the battery,
take it outside,
and let our expert drone pilot
fly it around a little bit,
just to see if we made all
the connections correctly.
Shall we proceed outside,
and see what this thing can do?
[Music]
Very nice.
I'm gonna do a little punch out.
3, 2, 1.
That's awesome.
All right, next Olympic
sport right here.
Drone flipping.
Lego drone flipping.
Yes!
Nailed it.
That was awesome.
That drone flies fantastic.
It flies exactly
like a real drone.
I could hardly even
tell the difference.
Racing drones are typically made
out of carbon fiber,
because it's so
strong and light.
This Lego drone is only
a little bit heavier
than carbon fiber racing drones
that I normally race with.
It flies great.
And when Spencer mentioned
these propellers went about 30,000 RPMs,
he said, don't get
your fingers near it,
because that can actually
slice down to the bone.
So just for fun,
I went and picked up
some hotdogs to kind of simulate
what would actually happen.
We tied this thing
to a 2x4 so we can get
this thing spinning
as full throttle,
and then I'm just going
to dip a hotdog down into it,
and see what it does.
Whoa.
What the heck?
What?
No way.
Okay, so our support beam,
the 2x4, actually lift it up.
That thing has got
a lot of thrust.
So now we got two more support
beams that I'm standing on,
and the idea is we're just going
to come in at a safe distance
and bring the hotdog in here.
Let's fire it up.
1, 2, 3.
Whoa.
Look at that.
That is clean.
That was a lot less gruesome,
a lot more crisp
than I expected.
It was, which means
those are sharp.
Well, I feel like we've
learned something new.
These things are not kids toys.
Here's a fun fact for you.
These Lego drones
that we've made can achieve
speeds anywhere between
60 to 100 miles per hour.
All right, we're out
here at the track.
You can see we have
some professional Pilots
racing behind us.
We're going to put our Lego
drone up in the air,
let it compete,
and see how it does.
We've made some
modifications to this.
You can see it has a base,
so it looks nice and mean.
For actual racing,
we might want to take this off,
but we'll see how it goes.
We put a 3D printed GoPro mount
on top of this drone,
so you can see what it's
like first person view.
3, 2, 1.
[Music]
All right.
We got the radar gun.
We're going to see
how fast these things go.
86.
Woo.
81.
83 miles an hour.
That is fast.
[Music]
Hey guys, the fun
doesn't end here.
Go check out the video
we made with Rebrikculous,
we've got it right up here
for you on the top left.
You want to check out some
more King of Random videos?
We've got those for you
on the bottom left,
and if you want to subscribe
and join the club,
go ahead and click the bomb.
I'll see you next video.